quelques années après avoir acheté leur
condo en 2010 les voisins de lucie
croteau découvre de graves infiltrations
d'eau derrière le revêtement acrylique
on n'avait pas le choix on était obligé
de faire refaire l'acrylique dans le
temps risque était fait et de l'oeuf à
rafah pour quatre immeubles
le coût des travaux s'élève à plus d'un
million de dollars les propriétaires
intente une poursuite contre celui qu'il
croit être le constructeur les
habitations trigone données de ce que
nous voyons qu'elle fait ça commençait
pour nous non nous on est 4 e v12 ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta le tel numéro dans sa
défense
trigone plaide que madame croteau a
signé son contrat avec une compagnie à
numéro une entreprise distincte de
trigone mais créée par les deux
fondateurs de trigone pierre champagne
spécialisé en droit de la construction
voit souvent ce genre de situation et
consommateurs se rendent pas quand ils
pensent contracté avec la compagnie qui
connaissent en réalité la plupart du
temps il contracte avec la compagnie qui
est vidé à la fin du projet la compagnie
à numéro est alors devenu une coquille
vide
le président des habitations trigone
accepte de nous rencontrer
surprise nous apprenons que tu rigoles
ne construit rien semprun terrain un
habitations trigone a pas de terrain
semprun une licence de construction de
la régie des bâtiments
ça me prend de couverture d'un plan de
garantie obligatoire
peut-être son trio no pasa habitations
trigone est une marque de commerce qu'on
promouvoir moi quand j'arrive le char
avec trium puis un coup que j'ai signé
mais l'homme prétend que ces put rigole
la multiplication des compagnies à
numéro n'est pas une et quatre egun les
répandue dans l'industrie de la
construction
champion de la québec inc au québec la
compagnie numérique on connaissant la
ministre responsable de l'habitation dre
la forêt nous annoncé avoir mandaté la
régie du bâtiment
elle veut un portrait complet du
phénomène des coquilles vides dans
l'industrie de la construction
ici françois dallaire et au canada
montréal